all right guys
so as I'm filming this video it's only
going on patreon right now it is
December 4 the channel is currently not
in our possession we have to prove Leo
fit through every means necessary so I
had an idea all right I thought of
something random over the weekend and I
figured it's Christmas coming up home
alone is one Christmas movie I have
definitely seen a handful of times and
home alone too lost in New York pigeon
lady in the car ride over the weekend I
realize I thought of a way to reboot
home alone I told John about this now my
reboot of home alone I would take a very
different approach to it it's gonna be
darker it's not gonna be a movie it's
gonna be a miniseries it's kind of like
mine Hunter Meets The Punisher let me
explain a little more so if you look at
the show mine hunter it's a show about
people look learning what serial killers
are essentially and at the beginning or
the end of the episode they show like a
snippet of the BTK killer during that
time I'm gonna take that idea where the
first half of the Home Alone show Kevin
McCallister is alone his family leaves
him it's not like the movie I want to
take a darker much more realistic
approach that seems to work with comic
book movies so why wouldn't it work with
whoa okay so the first half of the
season it does start off the way you
think you're watching a home alone show
I say it meets the Punisher because it's
gonna have that real slow build it's
gonna be it's really gonna take its time
it's gonna be like us hardcore like
watching people character study of Kevin
McCallister and at the end of every
episode it'll cut to the character that
Joe Pesci and the other guy played the
Lord of the Wet Bandits
yeah the Wet Bandits cuz in part two
that the sticky bandits when he puts his
hand and grabs all those Porter's in
this show Kevin McCallister starts off
in the first few episodes like he is
having fun just like in the movies like
he's really looking forward to being
home alone but that's stage one it's
called denial people the only reason
he's having fun that he's home alone is
cuz he's in complete denial of the
struggles of abandonment
this moment so then when you get halfway
to the season he really starts a
deteriorate right he really starts to go
a lot darker and you know you got to
have a female love interest in this show
because that's the only way it works
right maybe you got like a disturbia
situation where the neighbor across the
street who's way hotter than he'll ever
be they start crushing on each other
because he's dorky and shy but then she
sees he's awesome like a prankster you
know she sees he likes to have a lot of
fun then I remember in the first time
alone I remember the movie that well but
there was this old dude who was a
neighbor and I pretty oh yeah that's
right he helps out in the movie he saves
Kevin McCallister at the end I remember
that and my show he's gonna die he's
gonna get shot by the Wet Bandits
and a really brutal way so remember in
the shining when the black guy who has
the shining ability to shows up and then
he gets hit by the axe by I think if I
said black guy more people would
actually know who I'm talking but is he
that famous for if if you say the black
guy from the shining and was gonna go oh
yeah there's that one black guy as
opposed to who's that guy again
was he the who's he the guy who used to
run the hotel you know but remember when
he gets hit with an axe he comes out of
nowhere that's how he's gonna go down
jump in a head here this is a real
brainstorming session I have with you
guys right now halfway through the show
Kevin McCallister he's really starting
to come to terms with abandonment and
he's getting angry and this season of
the show he's going through the five
stages occurred
he's getting angry you know you start to
cut the flashbacks of like horrible
traumatic incidences of his older
brother just kicking the [ __ ] out of him
you know he puts his anger and blame on
there they never love me because of
whatever that guy's name is I really
should have done some research but who
needs research I'm rewriting the whole
thing and then you know he starts to
blame himself so he just really starts
to go into a state of depression and he
becomes best friends with the girl
across the street she's the new
character for the show you know she's
also depressed she's one of those girls
it always seems at home something's
wrong with dad he's kind of abusive you
know how those shows like to do it also
you know the movie it it's taking a lot
of 80s movies cliche because 80 these
are awesome now by the time the thieves
break in when he realizes you know
a break-in happening is sent up all
these traps the thing about the
difference with my show is Kevin
McCallister has already gone to such a
dark place that he wants these thieves
to break in he wants to hurt these guys
so this is a 12-episode season I want to
make it feel like this could have been
condensed to eight but I am I want to
stretch it out to 12 because that seems
to be Netflix's model I'm pitching this
and Netflix by the way and they're like
the last three episodes it's really just
like one whole episode is dedicated to
him just torturing the [ __ ] out of the
Wet Bandits it gets really violent then
the Wet Bandits get the upper hand and
they start torturing Kevin you really
want to see Kevin deteriorate and while
he's in the torture chair you know he
starts to realize all the things that
happen with his parents and he realizes
that even though they abandon him he
they love him and they must have
abandoned protecting that he can be okay
on his own that's when old guy comes in
then Kevin he goes like all Morpheus and
he breaks out of the cuffs and then he
attacks them he kills them and then I
paid tribute to Last House on the Left
cuz that's really what home alone is in
a lot of ways he kills them by sticking
both their heads in a microwave and then
they explode and then his family comes
home the end of it is they come home and
it's like spider-man homecoming when
Aunt May walks in on Peter in the suit
they walk in and there's like blood
everywhere the place is all [ __ ] up
because of all the Christmas mess and
then the mom goes and then she faints
you paid tribute to the og home alone I
know whenever we do a fan fiction idea
of how something could work or reboot a
remake it's really thought out beat it
out a lot of the time I really felt like
this time would work best as an organic
pitch I know the other ideas when you
hear those you're more like whoa that
could actually work that sounds pretty
cool and I know that when you hear this
you're gonna be like there is no other
idea that is better than that we should
definitely watch it just make me laugh
so much to produce this myself like 13
episodes by the first half-hour of the
first episode you forget that the whole
joke is that it's so serious
because you just get so invested that
series it's like watching like a rack of
rack of video that's way too huh anyway
thanks for listening patronage X you
guys are you guys are awesome